so just had my first potential new
client meeting with this guy Sean
Anderson really enjoyed it actually it
was really interesting to listen to
recruitment business problems and how we
potentially solved them add value etc I
mean the Shawn is going to be the person
I'm gonna learn a lot from which is why
it excites me I mean Shawn what what
would you say is so far the most common
problem that you're hearing or the most
thing that you've heard from these
meetings people don't understand
necessarily what goes into creating a
brand or trying to achieve the results
they all what they all know the odd the
other businesses that are doing well
yeah what they're and they've all want
to be there every single one of them
wants that but when you when you break
down exactly what it might take then
they're a little bit it's like I've
mentioned it today the myth about going
to the gym yeah everyone knows the
benefits of having like a personal
trainer for 12 months yeah but when
they've told exactly what it will take
and how much will spend it results
straightaway become secondary to the
fact that exact they've actually got to
do something about Spencer Michaela
where it's basically that BOTS give us
two years and everyone will be on it so
it's at the moment it's about who's got
the first mover advantage and who's the
who are the innovators in month one
thing that I've found super interesting
I'm eating there okay cool is to the
oven into the other CRM now that's crazy
we we worked our way much through our
branding we can solve not only this but
they've got no brown
content week actually the serum we use
acts as a internal treatment serum as
well yeah so that that softens
absolutely amazing visibility of
everything with what's going on the
placement you can see everything and how
the websites before we night your
contents before when a social performing
or not performing yeah she's a equally
as important wicked well first of many
and good little anymore
had people in the first meeting they
don't say anything that's definitely